fermeture des bars des restaurants ou
encore des salles de sport pas un jour
ne passe sans une nouvelle mesure de
restriction pour l'exécutif
il s'agit de ne pas saturer les hôpitaux
un seul but préserver au maximum un
système de santé déjà très fragile mais
il est peu question du nombre de places
disponibles dans les établissements de
santé et de mesures d'urgence qui n'ont
pas été prises depuis la première vague
c'est en tout cas ce que pense le
professeur juvin chef de service des
urgences de l'hôpital georges pompidou à
paris il ya un chiffre à savoir avant le
mois de mars on avait 5000 lits de
réanimation et là nous avons 5008
rénovation pas plus face à un système de
santé crise et appauvrit ces trois
dernières décennies le professeur
réclament des mesures plus concrètes du
matériel du personnel supplémentaire et
délits en service de réanimation mais
ces demandes ne semble pas être à
l'ordre du jour pourquoi on était à 5000
lits en réanimation et y monte à 10
millions comment se fait-il
qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas dix mille
lits spécifique réanimation notre pays
de manière pérenne mais parce que vous
ne pouvez pas du jour au lendemain
passer de cinq à dix mille et il nous a
des visions mois aux différents elle les
conclusions du ségur de la santé dévoilé
fin juillet prévoit bien des
recrutements et 4000 créations de lui à
la demande créée ponctuellement pour
taire face un pic épidémique ou une
hausse de l'activité saisonnière
à titre de comparaison ce chiffre de
4000 lits correspond à peu de choses
près et même un peu moins aux fermetures
de lits qui ont eu lieu pour la seule
année 2010 8 4200 très exactement
en juin dernier des cliniques de rennes
par exemple signalait n'avoir obtenu
aucune autorisation pour créer des lits
en réanimation il dénonçait alors des
postures hostiles au secteur privé la
bretagne est la région de france la
moins bien dotées en capacité de lits de
réanimation
nous disposons de 162 lits de
réanimation quand une région à
population comparable comme la normandie
en propose 225
le 27 septembre le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand a lancé un vibrant
message je fais un appel notamment dans
les ehpad où nous avons besoin de
renforts nous avons des postes ouverts
sont des postes financés encore non
pourvus alors que la deuxième vague
menace plus que jamais on est en droit
de se demander pourquoi rien ou si peu
n'a été fait depuis le déconfinement
d'autres pays ont tiré des leçons bien
plus vite que nous aux etats unis la
californie a augmenté de 900 places sa
capacité en réanimation
plus près de chez nous l'italie dès le
mois de mai a commencé à doubler ses
capacités de lits de réanimation et à
recruter vingt mille personnes
depuis des années la france figurent
parmi les mauvais élèves en terme de
places en réanimation avec 11,6 pour
cent mille habitants elle arrive par
exemple derrière la croatie et la
bulgarie et s'il n'est jamais trop tard
il faudra plus que des promesses et des
médailles d'honneur décernée aux braves
personnels hospitaliers pour attirer de
nouveaux candidats sur ces éventuels
nouveaux postes espérons que ces
derniers auront également du matériel et
des lits pour accueillir les futurs
malades peut être très bientôt